على قمة تل لبناني يطل على إسرائيل
اجتمعوا للاحتفال بمرور 73 عامًا على
ما
يسمونه بالكارثة ، احتفل البعض بهذه
المناسبة مع صور سيلفي للأجيال القادمة ،
ووقف آخرون للحظة من التأمل الهادئ ،
لكن معظمهم اختاروا الترانيم التقليدية
التي تردد صداها في هذه الوديان
لعقود من الزمن
قريبًا.  شقت مجموعات من الرجال
طريقهم إلى السياج الحدودي
للمشاركة في تقليد قديم آخر
رمي الحجارة
جنود حاولوا السيطرة على غضب الشباب ،
لكن أحد
المتمردين الروحيين صعد إلى القمة في اليوم السابق
لقي رجل لبناني مصرعه وهو يفعل الشيء نفسه
متأثرا بجراحه.  أصيبوا بصاروخ إسرائيلي
ولكن مع تحطم حاجز الخوف ،
أصبح المتظاهرون أكثر جرأة ، حيث
رأينا المتظاهرين يلقون الحجارة
بأيديهم حقًا
أي شيء يمكنهم وضع أيديهم عليه
فوق هذا السياج الحدودي ، لقد رأوا
القوات الإسرائيلية
على الجانب الآخر.  سمعت ما
يبدو أنه صوت إطلاق نار ،
فنحن نرشق الحجارة على
الإسرائيليين الذين احتلوا أراضينا ، أخبرني هذا الرجل بأنه
أتمنى أن يسمح لنا الجيش اللبناني بالعبور ،
ثم بدأ جهد جماعي
لتسلق الجدران الخرسانية التي يبلغ ارتفاعها حوالي 25 قدمًا
أولئك الذين
وصلوا إلى القمة ورفعوا أعلامهم واختار آخرون إرسال
رسالة مباشرة
تقول إسرائيل إن مثل هذه الأعمال تهدد
مواطنيها  الأمن
لكن والدة أحد الرجال المعلقين
فوق برج المراقبة أخبرتني أن
هذه هي مقاومتهم ،
نحن نتألم ، أخبرتني أن هذا
يحدث للقدس
والحكومات العربية نائمة
حيث أخلاقهم
حيث كانت سعة الجثم تصل إلى أقصى
حد.  سقطت عبوة غاز وسط الحشود
وسرعان ما تحركت القوات اللبنانية وفرقت
التجمع في اليوم المنتهي حيث بدأ بوعود صاخبة
بالسير إلى القدس
من حشد يعرف أنه لا يستطيع فعل
شيء من هذا القبيل
سالم عزيز CNN على الحدود اللبنانية الإسرائيلية